Have you ever wondered
how talking therapy works?
Maybe you've suffered a bereavement,
been feeling down or anxious
or just overwhelmed
and you're starting to think
you should talk to someone.
Perhaps you've tried talking
to friends or family,
but they don't seem
to quite understand
or they have too much
on their plates.
So you consider therapy,
but you have doubts.
What if you're not ill enough
to see a professional?
Will it feel awkward
talking to a stranger?
Will they make you lie down
on a couch and reveal
your innermost secrets?
In the UK, you can get
talking therapy free on the NHS,
but waiting times
can vary significantly.
Private therapists can be expensive,
although some do offer lower fees
for those who can't afford
to pay more.
But let's say you've arranged
your first session
and you're wondering
how exactly it might help.
The good news is
that therapy can actually change
the way your brain functions
in a positive way.
Our brains are a little bit
like Play-Doh, capable of adapting,
reshaping and rebuilding.
This is known as neural plasticity.
Whilst in therapy, your brain
circuits are able to remould
and reconnect in different ways,
meaning we're able to reframe
negative or obsessive thinking.
By shifting our thinking, we start
to strengthen different pathways.
So when you talk through stressful
feelings and strong emotions
in therapy, you're rewiring
your brain, a bit like rewiring
an electrical circuit.
Therapy also activates
the hormone serotonin
and can help improve our ability
to cope with stress.
Studies found the brains in people
who've had therapy for depression
and post-traumatic stress disorder
showed improvements
that were as good
as SSRI antidepressant treatments.
Even short courses of therapy
can be beneficial.
They often use techniques
known as CBT,
or cognitive behavioural therapy.
This can be particularly useful
in helping you change
specific behaviours
or negative thinking patterns
because it focuses attention
on your problems
and helps you develop
coping strategies.
In 2020-21, over 630,000 people
completed the NHS Talking Therapy
programme in England,
averaging seven and a half sessions
with a therapist.
51.4% of those who completed
the programme for anxiety
or depression recovered.
The most important factor
determining whether therapy works
for you is the quality
of the relationship you have
with your therapist.
This is actually more important
than the type of therapy you choose
or the therapist's experience.
So if you don't get on
with the first therapist you meet,
it's worth persevering
and looking for a new one.
Your level of motivation
is also important,
as is the therapist's ability
to recognise
which type of support is best.
Suggesting weekly homework
might do wonders for some
but be completely off-putting
for others.
So why can therapy be better
than talking to a friend?
For starters, you get
your therapist's undivided attention
and you don't have to worry
about what they think of you.
You can cry your eyes out.
They won't judge you.
Unlike with a friend,
you don't have to worry
about hurting
your therapist's feelings.
Then there's confidentiality.
Unless the therapist thinks
you're at risk of harming
yourself or others,
whatever you say
in the therapist's office stays
in the therapist's office.
A friend might offer advice, which,
even if well intended,
might not be right for you.
A good therapist usually won't offer
advice, but instead listen,
summarise what you said
and reflect it back to you.
This simple technique
can help you see things
from a different perspective.
Unlike a friend who may be quick
to agree with you,
a therapist can challenge you
in a supportive way,
and without being challenged,
you may not find new ways
of thinking or behaving.
Of course, therapy doesn't work
for everyone in every situation.
Serious mental health conditions
can require drug treatment
or even an inpatient stay.
Other people find
self-help techniques
such as meditation
are enough for them.
But overall, studies show
that a typical client is better off
for having gone through the process.
In fact, according to the NHS,
in 2022, over 66% of people
who entered therapy
found it beneficial.
In the words of American writer
Carlee J Hansen,
"Therapy didn't fix me,
"therapy gave me the tools
to help me fix myself,
"over and over again.
For the rest of my life."